so you've hit a bit of a rough patch and
i care about you
so i just want to make sure that you're
doing okay chris honestly
i'm great i'm just exploring whatever
fun activity pops into my brain
are you busy and writing star trek fan
fiction does not count
ha-ha-ha i finished it last week what's
going on
data had never felt this way before of
course data
had never felt anything before but
captain picard couldn't help but note
the smile that crept over his mechanical
but
lifelike face i'm gonna murder you i
understand just one sec
as they walked down the hall into the
bridge
and seal the edges by crimping
with a fork ah crap
ben what's up chris come on in man i
already did
so uh how you been how you doing how are
you great actually i'm just
learning how to make a color zones uh
or as you americans like to say calzones
do you want one no i find calzone fatty
and unnecessary so ben why
cazone glad you asked chris you know
there's fast food hamburgers there's
fast food mexican there's fast food
chinese blah blah blah have you ever
wondered
why there isn't a fast food option for
italian food what about pizza
pizza never heard of it that's what
people will be saying in 20 years
because pizza
is old news chris pizza is your
grandfather's calzone i never thought of
it that way what i'm talking about is a
portable
delicious meal that is its own container
it's a whole new spin on italian fast
casual dining
amazing now you of all people like this
i'm gonna use low-fat ingredients game
changer and i will call my new italian
fast casual eatery
the locale calzone
zone that idea is
literally the greatest idea i have ever
heard in my life that idea
is terrible how about this what if i
register for the contest i bake the pie
i act as my own wife oh that could work
we sidestep the controversy we refocus
the campaign onto the actual candidate
and then we flip the antiquated
tradition right on its head
exactly more importantly we change the
idea of what a pie
is i feel like that's not more important
but
i i like the energy that we have so
let's hear it okay picture this
crust on the bottom filling crust
on top what am i describing a pie
no but you're in the right zone oh
calzone sure pies are just sweet
calzones honey and i'm good at making
calzones you're amazing
i can win this thing of course you can
baby get in there and start baking
talk about the high way to
the calzone zone leslie has her own busy
life
and i happen to be an excellent pie
maker so we figured we'd switch it up a
bit
now pack your suitcases because we're
going to a little town called annapoli
hey man you want to go for a jog just
sort of kick out the cobwebs get some
endorphins going
oh no thanks chris kind of tearing this
claymation video a new one right now
you know ben i really think you need to
take a step back here i think
getting some perspective would be good
what are you talking about i've known
you a long time
and right now you need help
with my clay mage with your life you are
wildly insanely depressed
depressed i'm the furthest thing from
depressed
i mean look what i've accomplished do
you see him
do you think a depressed person could
make this
no i'm sorry but the ben wyatt that i
know
i just don't think he'd be happy sitting
here faffing around
i'm not faffing around i've sunk myself
into my hobbies
here i'll show you my claymation project
okay now i've been working pretty hard
on this and
i think it's really good so just hang on
to your hat okay
okay here it goes
oh great
[Music]
did you pause it no i hang on
oh my god that's the whole thing
that's three weeks of work you're gonna
be okay no no no no i'm not
you see in my head i thought that was
really really cool
in fact i i i emailed leslie two days
ago and i compared it to avatar chris
and how can it not be longer okay look
what you're feeling right now is regret
and shame but we are going to get
through this
are you ready yes no babe
are you ready yes i got fired from
running the sweetums foundation
thanks to me sorry again hey blessing in
disguise
i took a job at this accounting firm
they've tried to hire me three times i
finally gave
in but about a week off in between jobs
and i've been cooking up something
pretty big the last time he was in
between jobs he got
deep into claymation so this should be
different
hopefully presenting the cones
of dunshire a brand new gaming
experience
eight to twelve players two wizards a
maverick the arbiter
two warriors a corporal and a legend now
the legerman just
keeps score and he wears this hat oh boy
now the object is to accumulate cones
four cones wins but in order to get a
cone you have to build a civilization
the other amazing thing is the challenge
play actually let me tell you more about
the trivia cards because you're going to
need to
know about roblox first never mind think
about challenge play is it's basically
the game
in reverse then you roll three dice to
see how many dice you roll with oh 16.
perfect lots of choices okay each turn
goes roll
buy action i mean obviously this would
be much taller in the real game but
the corporal can veto this should be
green too how did this happen are the
cones a metaphor well
yes i know what it what is this called
again the cones of denshire
oh my god the maverick should be able to
trade lumber for agriculture credits how
have i not thought of this before
this is nothing right um when do you go
back to work again tomorrow it's fine
i'll just throw this in the garbage
the hell they're playing cones of
dunshire
hey you invented that game are they
playing any games i invented
are they throwing dirt into a fan the
key is you have to throw the dirt into
the back of the thing how the hell did
excuse me how did you guys get your
hands on this game
someone sent it to us have you played it
i invented cones of dungeyer
you're the architect you're right and
i'm the alchemist of the hinterlands
can't be an alchemist of the hindu lands
a hinterlands is a shadow kingdom that
can only sustain a provost or a denier
he's right hey how about this let's play
if i win you give me another shot at
free wireless for pawnee
have a seat you want to be corporal
or warrior neither
i'm the maverick
play an action card build a bell tower
inside your citadel
my shaman cast a toy burst spell on your
prosperity tile
looks like someone's out of resource
gems
[Laughter]
what's so funny oh no no you're a smart
guy
clearly picked up some flashy tricks but
you made one crucial mistake
you forgot about the essence of the game
it's about the cones
move my abbott to the ocean hex which
moves my brinksman to the devil's lair
and pushes my farmer yes my humble
farmer
directly into the central cone
yeah man we did it this whole company is
ours
oh no it's not that's mine it's all mine
for the record i did invent this game
but
it doesn't even matter because i won and
i get another chance to prove that there
is something truly special about pawnee
yes there is it's the home of the
architect
let's talk i'm on top of the world andy
what are you doing
you